so we had an election here
and the the person who got the most
votes it's a democratic primary but it's
going to be a democratic winner in the
fall okay right so it was this guy rick
caruso white guy uh billionaire uh and
karen bass i know them both like them
both
um she's a black congress person sure he
beat her
by 30 points with black men
what's up with that
you know it's hard to say to him and my
dear brother mark really thomas who i
love like a brother who's been
mistreated in so many different ways
that when i saw what caruso did in his
ad i had real critique of that
and so that i have a certain suspicion
of certain politicians who come flying
in from the top with billionaire money
and think somehow they're going to be
messianic in terms of dealing with the
mess that sometimes they actually help
cause now i'm not saying that in his
case but if i looked a little deeper i
might see some connections so in that
sense
he wasn't in politics before this no but
i know but that's what it is as you know
i mean the organized greed has such an
impact on our electoral political system
that it makes it so truncated we got a
choice between
neo-fascists like brother trump or
milton's neo-liberals like brother biden
wow i'm so happy to make a world shaking
decision you know what i mean
well
and you think of all the decent people
in america all the decent people in the
country how do we end up so imaginative
these mediocre folk i see
biden it
but i see biden is down uh with his
black folks can i just read i said i've
looked into this here's some of the
things he's done sure
appointed one of the most diverse
cabinets in history um first of course
black and female vice president directed
federal agencies on the first day to
address the impacts of
systemic racism extended the eviction
maturity moratorium that uh
disproportionately helped black families
remain safe during covent executive
order will improve educational
opportunities for black people
borrowed the use of chokeholds
uh doj sue georgia over discrimination
discriminatory voting laws uh his cash
relief program cut black child poverty
by 40 percent
and juneteenth
is now a federal holiday
and first black woman to the supreme
court
no good no no
those those are wonderful given uh but
why do you call it
that i mean
because
he still is tied to
wall street he's got crimes of foreign
on the cutting edge of human rights
would want one two-year white guy
impression again
you are honest
no but all the precious brothers and
sisters
we overthrowing democratic parties we in
friendly terms with dictators let's just
be honest and candid and most
importantly let's be honest and
candidate and say we're living in the
real world
nobody gets everything nobody gets
everything it's like you have some
consistency absolutely oh i'm not at all
but you are i mean no okay so no not but
you're like you mentioned he's talking
to saudi arabia i agree he said reset
the button yes of course
it's a tremendous hypocrisy he's a
politician that's what part of the gig
is wait a second let me just finish yes
he doesn't want to invite the people to
the to the avenue of the americas
you got new york city
the summit of the america no harm in
that no helmet uh i live in harlem i
live because he didn't invite cuba and
nicaragua and venezuela because they are
led by dictators which i agree is so
silly because he's about to meet with
saudi arabia because they have the gas
from
but if you don't get
if you don't get the people gas and the
people have a lot of gas already yeah
yeah yeah if you don't get the they
they're going to lose badly but they're
going to lose even worse
it's just going to elect a republican so
this is the world that we live in people
do have to make compromises even good
people but now the difference between
and you know based on your wonderful ivy
league training at cornell university
right phronesis practical wisdom is not
opportunistic judgment just like
pragmatism is not opportunism if you
make wise judgments relative to
constraints prince principles can be
compromised but the principles are still
retained once you have very little
principles it's all about power all
about manipulation all about spectacle
all about image that's very much what
american politics is about these days in
both parties spectacle superficial and
so when you say well if they're
hypocrites we got to allow for the
hypocrisy no not at all especially when
you're blues men like you and i because
i know your sensibility in terms of how
you wrestle with
catastrophe when you're a blues man or a
blues woman what does that mean you
don't tell the truth with style and a
smile no matter what the consequences
are and walk off and say i hope to do
better try again fail again fail better
like samuel beckett said
you